welcome to cloud built a highly
challenging game where you will master
high speeds and perform precision
platforming while taking out enemies in
your path as you learn to master these
mechanics you will begin to see your
surroundings with new life
with full control of your characters
movements the environment can really be
used to your advantage
you can run or climb on almost any
surface and by scouting the environment
you can find different ways to approach
each challenge
in cloudbuilt you can use abilities like
jumping and dashing at any time whether
you were on the ground in the air or on
a wall
other abilities require you to make use
of the environment such as sliding in
slopes and running on walls
but you are always in full control while
using them you can land anywhere on a
wall to start a wall run then use your
boosters to shift you up and down
avoiding threats
of course it's not only the environment
that stands between you and the goal
enemies will try to take you out but you
can always engage them with a blast from
your gun whether you're in the air
running on a wall or hanging from a
Ledge
Kyle built is currently in steam
greenlight process help us make this
game available on Steam by heading over
to our greenlight page and giving
cloudbuilt your vote please keep in mind
with everything you see here is a
work-in-progress and does not represent
the final quality of the game